petit plaisir aux on va se le faire tous
ensemble en somme si un petit bout haut
du filet à léon des morsures vous nous
aidez crise elle chante bien que c'est
la tension au liban sont élevés
attention l'europe est bien trop wend
n'avait évolué au métro bourse aux vélos
mu avait déserté
cdp femmes on est trop dure deux heures
j'attends pour danser les gens
jeune maman
m
à
oh
et
mais
ok
tiens
je n'ai pas vu personnellement mais on
m'a prévenu en régie qui s'est passé
quelque chose ici lui a essayé de danser
il était complètement déconnecté de la
musique donc ça faisait alors vous vous
avez tiré votre slip pendant toute la
chanson je ne sais pas si c'est l'effet
vous fait priscilla mais qu'est ce
qu'ils sont je vous assure je tournais
l'attendait le docteur
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ressurgit créé
parce que moi je danse et mon boitier
est parti à elle travaille sans boîtier